what's a fool podcast
what's up fool podcast with Johnny rocky
right here cool oh there we go had a gig
today at 2:00 p.m. he would never mini
to see what that gig is 2 P 2 o'clock
yet to Osprey a couple houses in a
corporate gig yeah City Hall you could
spray city Lisa right here you told me
this dress wasn't her shirt wasn't too
big but it is let me saw TV look women
different missy is talented we talking
about it was good with young guys mind I
haven't know who that is
oh he's only 18 already blowing up
brought out of East Los Angeles and [ __ ]
here when I was insane for a [ __ ]
hell yeah nobody populated eastern a
parade and we were in the the other
parade row though the parade they had
for Mexican Independence oh that's nice
to you a bigger version jovial man
Armand Assante
noise it's like a colonial was great
when you wear a bro a wedge of are my
[ __ ] what you wear it dawg enjoy well
wasn't there Kelowna woman's car and
called Jovan Jovan mas
yes called you mama yeah I remember that
I don't know I had it
Avon page five yeah that's a good one oh
you know what when I was a kid like we
have to have parties elementary school
you know what would that four years ago
for you as now very much he's the bully
what is that even like dogs like like
[ __ ] bro you tired darling you workout
today Jovan 80 years old no pain bro
like you're back with a herd maybe your
vote cause you know I think I think I
messed up a race like why don't you just
hear that
oh boy they've messed up oh yeah for
sure
no elementary school I used to play this
game called bloody knuckles a lot like
three little bloody knuckles this you
gotta just put your knuckle out there
look at that yeah oh my God look at my
local boy see there to the side hmm
that's from losing bro kids with cheat
and put quarters in between your play
pencils yeah everybody who had everybody
gets their pencil like a number two and
then we're like bend it back and try to
break each other pencil and now this is
messed up what I would do brothers I
[ __ ] up my teeth I will bite the bed
to make the end of a sharp rope
so when it comes down and it'll [ __ ]
axe yeah my teeth owner been strong
enough to bite a [ __ ] pencil know how
do you sharpen a pencil your teeth know
you get to be putting a better your
molar you bite it hard you buy it again
then the eraser smashes oh you mean that
all the metal metal piece metal tip that
you should sharpen sharpener no cement
to make sure it's little axe so you will
you [ __ ] up you [ __ ] slicing
[ __ ] pencils like Lord of the
Rings
what amateur a player old-school man but
we should bear out again we're just
they're all about hitting people yeah
you're fair game code camera action
camera action will again replenish Utah
elementary and what happened was like
they see the four-wheeler played well
say camera at least and some states
still broke but we said our camera and
she can't stay jump out of that right so
we could we take it clothes off your
shoe and then go to action but but it
was funny because if you move you get
punched those sound like big brother
games like [ __ ] big game called
Robert donkey bro I heard weird oh no no
you told me about repertoire if you if
you sit down bro people get to you gotta
say Robert donkey to a while giovanna
these plain rubber donkey - Johnny Rock
a rubber talking to Wendy Williams over
there and everybody's playing right yeah
but just a Jovan denied I mean so I
didn't told you a barn rubber donkey
like eating hear me I did talk to him
they're more focused he gonna be higher
me [ __ ] this [ __ ] I [ __ ] up my back so
those this bully brought him Lamar no
baby James no I've written [ __ ] name
bro it was a black bully who's black he
was just like me and bro I need to Punk
me right now oh the straight up punk
anyways bro like if you like slap me in
the back I'll just keep walking wrong
yeah low you slapped my back leg I'll
just keep walking even though bigger
than you I don't want to do nothing
broke because I was already getting beat
up at home I wanna beat up again so this
fool always messing with me bro Sam
Bennett and it was Sam business he
hasn't been a crimp later on and I will
run him over my car but another story
but but that fool used to bully me like
a bullying everybody I'd like to be like
not afraid of him but I didn't want to
mess with him and every once in a while
like he'll do something stupid like take
my juice and I pretend like so when I
was talking that was more than I taking
from them you know but whatever so one
day I'm in a classroom and for the bro
farty dogleg it's a glass here gotcha
bro just get stuck at the I share my
path to this done with this bleep Floyd
let me real about real loud dog oh man
didn't they go far did you know [ __ ]
farted
I thought embarrass dog so I think
you're the only one who heard that I
don't I heard him so far right
so I said embarrass dog like more
embarrassed than him punching me in
front of everybody or taking my juice
why rush that what a [ __ ] up letter
for the night ed Tyler the [ __ ] face
oak or berries be [ __ ] I broke I could
be the [ __ ] of those of the [ __ ]
neighborhood I could be the punk-ass
[ __ ]
I'll give me the food that everybody can
[ __ ] with but I'm not gonna be part or
[ __ ] man bro the Rays that give it to me
like The Incredible Hulk brush which is
[ __ ] Sam ever happen to you jumbo yeah
well you just broke out and you have to
just dip it up man you don't to be [ __ ]
man bro yeah I still eat ever I did it
bro my name will stick with you cuz I
don't want to Blake horrible man like
like like a full state are there so far
like not that many people heard the game
at this point okay so the [ __ ] airbender
so I was so embarrassed that it was
hurtful bro like yeah then when your
damn buddies point of you you wanna
fight him but you can't you wanna punch
his ass but holding your head back a so
you're punching a crazy so I was
throwing very budget rush there food dog
I've [ __ ] therefore I was too afraid
of him after that bro but it you know
yeah Oh coming fart man you broke man
you had to do something but after that
but I hit him and I beat became like say
my friends and we ended up [ __ ] fools
up too
we have to wait for the fool could i
father deliver against sounded like it
was like the other black guy yeah they
were Nathan he was like smart bro here
we had nice shoes and his mom used to
just drop him off and right there
because his grandma lived there and we
used to wait for that for after school
like eight of us yeah and then like we
all beat him up except me I mean I was
just jumping up I would like punch
people there like also sound better in
these stories I know like man that's
right Peyton Peyton were playing a
rubber donkey with me and he had [ __ ]
me up already and he sat down Jovan like
that's all and do all that
he didn't say Robert donkey and I ran
from my seat bro
with a knife [ __ ] nailed him bro with
a double fist in the back and they took
me to the principal's office
I thought we were [ __ ] [ __ ] game
over donkey baby bridges bro like if you
say OB were you gonna say baby Bridget's
okay is that a crib game they weren't as
big a deal and I wanna be far Bamber oh
[ __ ] that [ __ ] done so this days dogs
like like if somebody blame something on
me and it's embarrassing if you leave me
I don't crazy dog yeah no no no no for
cutting me dick I've actually my pants
or like they pointed me you're sweating
though there happen to you so what's up
Jabari about you dog
I can't we do a lot of you you can get
yourself now but their volume you do was
our interviews yeah I tired of him
no keep them coming
nobody must do though you must hate the
ones that they're just repeatedly like
we gotta sit down you're fools just
covering it well there's some where it's
like
young man the player is throwing a
hundred years ago you can't say no so
I'm gonna throw that be bright retie
what do you man I'm not gonna go back to
LA TV no matter how much money you pay
me ya know like some of the interviews
there they're really quick and snappy
with in there like try to get answers
out I mean well this was before the
movie was out so I can like saying yeah
spoilers like I had a very vague
description and they were just they
would just pry and fry and they're like
so we know you get superpowers in the
end I'm like no I know that is a reality
in the comic book but in this movie I'm
like you know I steer away from it and
it's like you know but thankfully my PR
can help me with that and how to deal
with those type of things and resume yet
mr. booth pocket our real life right I
say foot set agree yeah he's up there
bro you look down on that gap but you go
up on them no just gonna play the
lucious there bro how do you get his
nickname okay
ro q ue this is like the gourmet version
of the restaurant yeah I wonder if you
ii do the land hill rocky because i knew
a guy named rocky but I wonder with yeah
it's let him work rocky I've known
several rockets what's a common name
those military rocket that fufu no
wonder he got caught he got kicked he
was banned from the LA Zoo for life for
what we're letting not living out the
peacocks yeah bro
aren't they allowed to roam freely there
was a playground all the time when I
used to take Isaac it might be because
run because went around like groupies at
Jovan Arman shows Rose
I was shown the pretty feathers yeah so
oh there it was a summer camp at the
right admission bro and that fool it out
the zoo's laid out the [ __ ] peacocks
and and then someone else I wanted
another kangaroos bro because I remember
somebody that people were like got a lot
of people from our summer camp got
arrested or kicked her like zoo that day
because one for later of the Peacocks
two for chasing kangaroos were on the
zoo and sweet for taking a pee cut for
the daughter asylum to be the tourist
bro I mean the other guys up yes we were
started the peacock feathers - yeah 4.2
dollars dog Wow so that summer camp with
bad bro forever I lost two kids though
so you grew up in East Los Angeles yes
my raise your pears up from there my mom
I think grew up in Belle but my father I
don't know Mexico somewhere was by this
Bulldog yeah play your dad bro we got
this bro buddy how the movie I saw not
yet well you could say something now
details though you and I were to a pro
couple of premieres right let me start
what do we see we start [ __ ] that
movie spider-man yeah which everyone
ever [ __ ] bad-ass sounds good and you
are watching that [ __ ] marina Walker I
could play like the another universe of
spider-man man like the hungover what it
makes it go you have that joke about
kind of a half-assed lazy superhero
right yeah I'll have a bit of a
superhero I'll be like like the superior
gets there too late like after
everything else I have all the power I
just don't get there on time bro I fly
only like four feet up in the sky yeah
like who who who did this my enemy was
my enemy was there
building called mr. the turbine and I
was I was my name was a my weaknesses
were application see you find yourself
like you're a lazy person or oh you're
motivated like you get out you have a
routine where you get our best aches and
you workout go to the sauna routine I
know get up a seven look creepy get a
coffee
jog video tips about working out and
you're like shape know like how to tie a
loop yeah you made your own song to it
how much older he is than 18 was the
young now he's like wait so he was show
like Cal you yeah did your mom ever been
my Caillou
okay I did with talkies are somewhat I'm
exactly like him well no I he wouldn't
imitate him he started whining the way
Caillou did cuz Caillou wind a lot
remember when he didn't his way he
didn't get what he wanted and then I
noticed my son was starting to whine a
lot too in a sec and I had to talk to
his dad I was like we gotta stop this
guy
thing I can't take it anymore he just
wouldn't take no for an answer on
anything it was a wine but then I read
that a lot of other people had banned
their kids from watching Caillou - not
my mom I wash Caillou and me how wonder
pits the phone say that that [ __ ] would
be my [ __ ] dreams I know you were
because you're asleep
we had a studio apartment you watch a
show called out he's only four years
older than Isaac then Isaac I don't see
it's a show that my son would watch it
was called off get ready for Marley the
big comfy couch
just like that cuz that lady had big
boobs the Reading Rainbow no it was big
comfy couch yeah you liked her or
something I like the show - now
xuxa well she has like pasties on yes
you sure like the ready to exit me
street of Brazil but she's not really
rated X but it should be mucho I don't
know if Kim is a growing numbers ill I
should a kid show and she had like you
like down a destroyed then she had high
heels and sparkly here and then she
sings to the kid a little top she's just
kind of like Lady gaga a little bit you
know like but not as outrageous because
I know that there be more cleavage she
there was a Simpsons when they go to
threesome scandal
I have kids there was a prison Donald
ruby was the prison because I'm her
husband well there was more kidnapping
charge right yeah her husband like
grabbing chicks and whatever man
yeah kind of amazing I'm Cosby [ __ ] but
that arrested and she knew about it or
whatever was not dang it was complicit
in it I know that story brother a half
story like the kind of person a little
[ __ ] like it brother did you hear about
the collusion that's how I say room
that's all over the collusion and the
report and the money report no there's a
Simpsons episode where they go to Brazil
and there's I don't know if they call
her xuxa yeah but I mean I don't know if
on the show they call her shushu she or
if they use a fake name but she's Bart
is in the hotel room watching this thing
and he's like this on the bed like
staring with his eyes wide open and then
it shows what he's watching March it's
like what are you watching Bart he says
no and then it's xuxa and she's going to
her twisting these pasties on her boobs
like swinging them in front of the kids
faces in the camera he's hypnotized it's
a great episode Chucho though x huh Xu
Xu Xu Xu yeah watching again I can't
find it
anyways that was there I used to watch
me life as I can Cody oh yeah oh okay
that's a cool show yes wins right yeah
that's why she's dressed like a
schoolgirl right that's a kid show bro
it's like double dare or can't do that
on television or something
Alonzo yeah yeah from Saved by the Bell
what's that look good doing it he's
crazy
[Laughter]
I feel like thigh high boots are
everything there's no cleavage in this
one it was the American version
that's how you get it going my shows
before I hop on stage I'm like and then
it again make sure you get ready you're
getting in a rap and and in addition to
your acting yeah
have you have you done like performances
and records since our own not records
anymore though its songs no yeah yeah I
got a couple songs out I got my EP out
that dropped last year it's called basic
it's on Spotify iTunes Amazon everything
and you go under Jovan Arman yes when
you're when you're rapping - same as my
acting I just I just feel like it was
like childish gambino he's donald glover
isn't it oh yeah yeah and comedian
everything I just thought there were two
separate people that's why sorry just
like the rock and Dwayne Johnson they
look so similar I say my name Julie I'm
gonna tell her to the hotel to get
really good chicken wasn't it borrowed
you change the name Jason a John Wesley
and that's what I want a common in Texas
oh okay change it then you shoot your
name on your chicken somewhere mmm
what's your name no I just usually go by
Jeff I'm on everything I don't think you
can do it anymore in this day and age
you're looking for that dongle thing
single dangler oh you have enjoy your
special you have an ox yeah I don't know
why must be nasty users put up with that
[ __ ] losing the infirmary yeah what
excess max and then oh and now you gotta
buy a $15.00 dongle
well I give up thinking that I want to
do it alone but they want me to join it
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
join if you go your one hour mine for it
before I get some before all right
I over the fire I got the sorry I got
the fire I got the floor
you're fine I got a sorry
[Music]
we're mighty no actually yeah hey bro we
got beets for clearance sale and like
what okay
beets like know they're smart though
because the soundcloud rappers are like
is it's just mess around
that will buy beats for like 20 bucks
and you don't even know also if they've
used it for some other song well some of
them some of them Lisa and then for the
rights it's like 200 or something huh so
if you want to actually make it on your
album or it starts to go somewhere or
whatever then you have to pay the right
so yeah I mean we have to pay we're to
pay rights for your special for you to
sing Sweet Caroline yeah and just the
words Sweet Caroline we had to pay eight
thousand bucks for that and for you to
sing gent a volver volver volver just
those two words I was five thousand
dollars algorithm personation and I said
or not I said if they want to sue us
they can he didn't even impersonate him
he just said no you did no you didn't
even say ain't nothing but a hound dog
you didn't say that right you said
something in Spanish just mentioned
Elvis's name and then did a deep voice
yeah and I said I don't think they're
gonna sue us on that take the risk
I'm not payin I'm not trying to check
with the Elvis estate but I was but they
said that Elvis Elvis is estate his wife
and his daughter have to approve every
Elvis impersonator in the
country Wow in the world that's deeper
than the Kim Kardashian blocking that
girl who like you mean she was like a
catalog model yeah they were using she
was trying to block her from getting
work as a model because she looked like
her and people were using her because
she looked like her she's like my fear
has always told me but oh my god things
in some way I couldn't make that party
story what story don't you say we gonna
bring up oh it was an article about
Denali Park and global warming and how
there are because of the global warming
they're having a longer warm season so
the snows going to start to melt in
Denali like taking shits in Denali State
Park in Alaska so the thaw period is
longer so more of the mountain is going
to thaw out so the people who and their
people who have [ __ ] over the years
along the mountain forever it's been
frozen well so now it's all gonna thaw
out it's 66 tons is what their estimate
comes out of us oh yeah that's nasty
there's more shouldn't there be Highland
[ __ ] now Coachella oh yeah you were
shooting a TV show last week and we
walked onto set or this earlier and it
was early in the morning it was 6:30 in
the morning and so they were using that
time to clean all the trailers all the
toilets trail in the trailers so it was
a big industrial hazmat truck hooked up
with a big hose to each trailer they're
like output thing yeah just sucking all
that stuff out and processing it and
this smell that was hovering over that
part of oil Heights was just I was
disgusting well funny was that together
with doing that job he was a craft
server they got a break a burrito if you
see a place truck eating it
like a soldier I bet you that his first
craft service bid to us oh no definitely
not can you imagine I mean it's a payday
for the guys who whoever owns those
hazmat or waste companies and have to
clean up Coachella but can you imagine
that's your job and you know going
there's gonna be a ton of [ __ ] like to
clean up that Monday or whatever yeah
it's like every time somebody takes a
[ __ ] ching ching dirty cuz nobody else
wants to do it or knows how did you
follow the farm and people would come
with a [ __ ] man later dude yeah so which
did you start first acting or rapping I
started acting when I was 8 years old
what huh what's the first thing you run
I do like a school film project thing
forget what they're called sooner film
it was called la sorpresa it was about
this all do my grandpa and the thing who
is it was his birthday
it was there's supposed to be a surprise
party and there was a cake and throw out
the whole like skit I would be like
sticking my finger in the cake trying it
and I'm like I like it and then come
back and I eat the whole thing and then
he comes home and then I open the door
and I'm like surprise that was a scary
house my first role it's pretty good
then would you and then just a couple
more student films some extra work
background work and just kind of worked
my way up I got some guests our roles
here and there my first like project
that really was memorable with some of
the short films I did so I did chub and
that went to the Miami Film Festival
I think I'll scrub yeah whoo
who the new movie uh me and some other
people I'm so long ago I know the
directors I'm kids ABBA we were smaller
yeah I was like fifteen fourteen turns
to move I saw with over but there's an
actress was bigger than a movie right a
woman yeah he says to say is it that um
the girl from Aerosmith daughter maybe
have Tyler Liv Tyler I don't know I
don't know
[Music]
si-hu BB yes Obie yeah it was a short
film I think it like Chubb rock that's
two bees yeah it was a while ago and
then also did another one or drowning
which talon was really cool and it was
actually kind of traumatic for me as
well because I was pushing the pool when
I was younger so they had to but yeah so
they had to push me like really to get a
shot and I was so scared like you like
you think about it's like kind of done
but like you I was scared and I was just
and then I was like you guys are getting
one take and I'm never doing this again
and I was just saying yeah it's just
like that initial panic you know yes
actually being pushed in you know yeah
so and then at the first at the time
when I was younger I couldn't swim and
he didn't know that the person oh oh man
his name is just kidding my first time I
didn't know how to swim man and I'll hit
my local swimming pool peek-a-boo and
pee can't park on First Street in Boyle
Heights dude you know how like um how
you go swimming dog and like a big pool
of the lifeguard had to say take a big
ass guys to come get us our pool was
wide so the the [ __ ] or my [ __ ] a
black card he didn't jump in to save me
my fat ass bro he got that big ass hook
it's like my big ass to the shallow end
dog haha he never got up
because I will hang it out to the rope
and I think that bullies do like let go
the rope he let go the rope Sam Bennett
again probably in there fool the
lifeguard some fool along here he was
cool though he forgot the hook and he
dragged me to the rope he goes there's a
shadow and he know you're playing well
worse was worse than when you can't swim
and the lifeguard knows your big ass
you're your skinny ass or your ugly ass
you know he knows you can't swim so if
he's so I would try to swim without
fluid back there in a deep Eddy but they
left for come back and I'll be like
buddy really swim bro
I was a little ooh a little looser ass
kid I was just hanging onto the rail
yeah I can stick in these bad going hop
it back on pulling onto the rope but
never in the middle bro like dude [ __ ]
the mid or dodge round so with that that
fool that fool told me to swing back and
forth to see if I could swim fool on
this flip back and forth one time
getting my fat ass turn I sure took my
time you should keep the bar hardest
each other on the fastest you think
these two are the ones that'll do it
yeah Feroze but Ronnie takes practice
you know like to get better so I thought
about the shoes our time so I thought
new shooters gonna do it I'm gonna kick
the ball harder and I never happened
dude so he's hoping to sway back and I
made it yay I did it all fast
that's how swim back faster they make it
a game bro look Isaac was when we were
going to the public pool
when we were going to the public pool in
those Feliz before we moved into our
house
he Isaac was trying to take that test to
go cuz he's a good swimmer but he hated
being watched and tested right so he
would he couldn't do it he would like go
lopsided or he would like lose his his
energy by the other by the before he
returned to the other side and he had
such anxiety about passing this test he
said forget it I'll just stay in the
shallow end until I'm like fishing but I
was like we moved into a house of the
pool though after that hated that I had
advantage of the kids that had long
torsos like a stupid told me to put to
my head I think you can probably see
them from his vantage point the hook
let's get back to you because your
important guests promote you and your
movie shows Sam Sam imagine when you go
to a dish about the addition was a lot
of people who look like you were older
you like they were like see like Gabriel
Iglesias type or the little boy from
Modern Family actually row or dustin
ybarra well they do they sometimes they
just want to see it all kinds of people
the best man when they want to see a
bunch of people and then they bring it
down to a bunch of people actually know
how to act then a bunch of people who
look at the person right yeah and then
the person that um that um we could
actually book yeah sometimes there you
have no idea what they're looking for
the only because your mom knows somebody
in the business bro like if your mom
like they say your mom knew somebody
right Johnny C among your people right
they're not cholos you know pastors or
drug addicts people she used to extort
and [ __ ] like that she go to have
restaurant with executives that they
were friends and the one that she goes
yeah so my son Johnny
auditioned for the role and Warner
Brothers and who is it Emily
the I can track torture her down oh
really
so the exec didn't the guy from Warner
Brothers they're like he don't even know
what the [ __ ] Emily is you don't know
what the [ __ ] Johnny is but he don't
like his business being thrown in that
conversation so they're muhfucka made a
phone call and put Charlie in the
[ __ ] movie dogs ah so the next time
they have a conversation all you guys
what Charlie actually got the part
because the other actually couldn't do
it I like the finish I saw that bad bad
bro
I saw their the episode of Mad Men it's
my new show right now yes creeper coming
down scraper because the next time you
like tacos you ever [ __ ] Milo's
brother show people like taco bro my mom
used to make tacos like taco do you
maybe tackle it be made a talk about a
left oh yeah yeah yeah well the corner
saw the right there bro cookies are news
this year whatever tomato a jalapeno
burning and you flip and then she will
put like the tortillas to cook in
between my carne asada and then you know
that shake it nice and greasy bro and a
little piece of you lay it in the same
thing little pieces of meat are falling
off the carne asada and that's a
straight blow nice great crunchy bro
like it look you get crunchiness of the
leftovers Baroque art of [ __ ] burn
sausage that was their burnt or diesel
you get all the bird chick is always
good and our bird ends of the carne
asada burnt ends of the [ __ ] shrimp
or whatever fish you put in there damn
bro you put some hot sauce in there bros
[ __ ] barbecue sauce break up with two
bimbos the next day bring food
I would say this spicy chilies
Halloweens
pata pata to grow them you have a little
moderate Morro Bay
[Laughter]
not Monterey Bay it's a Thai place
called Thai bounty Thai bell shaped like
a ship like a boat but it there right
there by the water it's a little a
little nice little sea town but let's
increase their basic their pad thai I
know pad thai is basic everywhere but
this Penta Penta is the bomb and it's
worth just getting that and so good eat
it there man vo take Johnny will he do
for John even for karate I forgot a bad
time for like a like a French rowing
initiate I put everything in it I hate
when people start messing with something
that you recommended to them and then it
tastes bad to them and it's like I don't
make it like that why did you order it
like I don't put old I told my friend
one time in New York it was this
sandwich place I said these sandwiches
are so good and then I told him what
kind I get and I said I'm going out to
that place again you want me to get you
one he said yeah but don't get this on
it and this on it and this on and I was
like alright so I brought it back and he
said yeah I don't like that sandwich I
see you get anything on you took
everything off so you ruined the thing
the love of that sandwich yeah lengua
taco what's up I was able to call my
watch - yeah nah we just came back was
crazy one of the best foods ever had was
it took coma watch it so much while
vegan restaurant called quickie - and
they had a vegan Reuben sandwich - it
was good
what did you have with a vegan salad we
had a bigger corner salad salad
oh jeez was good oh my
one of my friends put ketchup in their
mac and cheese it was so I guess it's
normal in Canada beep oh hi oh ha I
don't put ketchup she's in Toronto
more sense I don't know how to eat
encounter chef Frenchie's and Britt says
if anything I live right over there
that's the French that's more of a
Belgian things your friends who that guy
we had a French guy oh yeah he's just
like because we asked him what are you
doing who's that you know we say what's
up fool just like everybody else
ah cool cherry on the wall whatever a
waffle ah yeah they'll just pick the
rest you just be real a language I love
you speak Spanish fluently poquito
it was shameless all the like bro
Sheamus that was a while ago I was I was
like nine or oh yeah I had long hair
like around your leg - it was up to my
shoulders I played with some random kid
who goes up to this ice cream truck
because I guess they had and I just can
check but it was actually selling like
alcohol and drugs or whatever so I I go
up to it and I'm like two buds in a
spliff please and that's it remember
some people like it's funny cuz you
ordered that your character ordered that
yeah I don't know what I just said the
words
yeah just like sold weed at a web series
it's true we had my son on a web series
that we made it was stupid little web
series he was a drug dealer
that's funny when they said spliff I
thought it was a gun or something I have
two buds in the Wrigley's bro splits
aren't all they're cracked up to me it's
tobacco and weed it sucks
so you were just 9 did you audition for
that did your mom put your acting
classes I dragged you around - yeah I
did some acting classes early on but
there were just like there weren't
anything special so I kind of stopped
doing them but then um after I got my
agent she sent me out for a lot of these
things and I think I did audition for it
who's your agent at the time it was I
don't want get her promo
man is better a manager he's specified
in kids specialized yeah oh I know he
wasn't agent you're right welcome Peter
with a monkey bro well that was it was
weird cuz I asked him I asked the
company and him in the head of the
company I said how much experience you
guys have in development because we
wanted to start developing a sick huh
and they're like well you know some love
of a vague answer they sold me on
staying with them fooling me into
thinking they knew about development and
then I sat in that meeting we sat in
that meeting about homes remember and I
realized these guys don't know sure and
they know less than they know less than
I do about development and I saw why we
left them immediately was another
manager man and one of the Apple they
know it like you don't know showrunner
bro he don't know [ __ ] bro like a little
showrunners I wish I'd just left right
yeah we're gonna get it done ever right
you gonna give me a temper sample and I
gave me a showrunner he's gonna get 10%
of just everything he was in manager so
you get 10% of everything yeah
even shows that your book even your live
shows was because we already had a an
agent right APA first mm-hmm Tim your
two agents you had a booking agent and
talent agent so he saw those he saw a
contract before first and then he'll go
to the manager to give to me we're gonna
see more money it's against the law yeah
you cannot for no money no managers
can't do any manage any manage you have
for more money she'll be thrown in jail
again whipped by my [ __ ] it out by a
bunch of actually illegal thank you
deliver to anybody wrong it's actually
illegal for managers to book you on work
you know what what your first manager
was doing listen no no that you didn't
have an agent at the time so that's all
she could do to get your work so I don't
know what's that man I got a movie deal
on my own and she was obvious out there
didn't tell her bro what are you gonna
do give me more money already got my
eight G's
damn in your pocket okay retired man how
could I swear I was jovial I wasn't born
with talent like you had to work like my
mom without like my mom like you're just
so fortunate man like and I was top
people like who who have kids I don't
get you they want to be actors I said
like what's a little lady who had a
thing I want to promote my daughter she
wants to get these acting classes if I
get 11 pop it like 50,000 followers it's
gonna be up 400 dollars instead of 1,200
I saw this amidst you could you take
your own [ __ ] photos and and yet send
your shoes me own AG you're gonna pay no
money but anybody offered you in the
beginning of that [ __ ] like yeah scam
you guys cam know there was there was
nothing yeah bro Foucault no yeah when I
when I was I was first trying because I
haven't wanted to do this assaults for
years old but my mom was a little
hesitant to put me into it and then at 8
when I started there was this program
that we heard in the radio and it was
like get your kids on Hannah Montana and
I was like mom mom call that number so
it's you you really wanted so my mom
called the number and we showed up and
they told they took her to a separate
room they put me in this other room with
a bunch of kids and they said we're
gonna have him in an acting class so it
was like a little class right but all
they all they did was we played hot
potato it seemed like duck-duck-goose
your personality if for sure and then
and then they they took my mom in the
separate room and that she comes back
and she says that they want they wanted
$6,000 to start for a meeting with the
casting director are you actually
in the corner Jesus cried so we got the
four eyes oh yeah Jesus Jesus and then
and then they bumped it up what are the
people say they were gonna provide
without a manager and get you on a show
okay bro these are all lies have you
ever put a show together yeah your show
runner does that simple people knows how
simple it is the element everything that
he could do like you never know you
never know meat $6,000 they're gonna get
you capital that was just a medium
that's indirect I did an audition yeah
that's crazy man and then for their
whole program
it was 16,000 total like acting classes
headshot whenever you go to a place
where you're looking to be a model and
anything like that don't pay anything
you don't need professional headshots at
first you don't need any of that you
know comedy class but you don't need a
comedy classes nothing like that you got
it you got a try and they were finesse
and everybody liked to have the things
actors singers dancers models everybody
a bunch of people I was a lot of people
there don't grab somebody man
no for real and I think it was called
actually was tied up but there was
checks though wait what was it I I act
yeah yeah yeah yeah I've seen those you
know what one of your fans was asking
about that and I said I don't know about
this program there you know and and
because she was asking for advice on her
daughter's and house like I don't I said
first of all it doesn't it sounds more
like you are interested in this on your
daughter's if they're not really
interested in it I wouldn't push it I
said but if they're interested in it I
don't know if that I would go this route
because it's asking for money and all
this stuff and she's like well it's not
that much and and they said they would
give us a discount after I said no and I
said well that's because they want to
scare their negotiating down
we're boys break it down yeah because if
if five people pay that one person pays
the whole sixteen thousand and the rest
of the people pay six and then maybe a
couple they get down to two that's a lot
of money for like a week's work right
meeting people and talking about that is
one scam we we managed and I had a scam
going on I don't know we were out of
town with real Tory yeah yeah yeah
and she were like in Nashville no North
Carolina North Carolina and then she's
there she flew up from California to
audition people in North Carolina a
hotel right no hotel screw the knob
we're back to the show and she didn't
buy a drink she didn't buy anything she
didn't pay to get in and then she was
just kind of like like talk to people
you know and then she's doing all she
did was fly you know like just a regular
woman who know the business went out
there and they're like buddy bogus
audition audition people grab the other
cash
she might recommend one kid but what a
cash cow you know and then she's gone
let you go to Atlanta she goes to Ohio
wherever it is growing it's an
investment bro yeah investment
well cuz North Carolina we mention her
yeah on her part he's investing in Yemen
very little and very little she gets a
lot of cash and she might get like a
little relocation or a podcast you go on
it would you mousey hell no yeah sure as
I am not paying like she was like I make
all your dreams I support them but
nothing how did you start your very
first how did you get into like the your
first professional booking how did you
get it was it like a casting call like a
cattle call where you everybody shows up
but you don't have to have an agent or
did you there was this other program
that we that we signed up for it which
it was like I think it was only 200 and
you go in and they work with you it's
kind of like a workshop they'll work
with you on some scenes and how how to
do it and then kind of prepare you
because then they'll do a meeting with a
couple agents later on so they have a
bunch of kids audition walking in the
room audition leave or sit down and then
keep going and going and going and
there's three or three to five agents
sitting at tables with like headshots
and they'll take one if they like you
and whatever and then it's kind of a
showcase with several agents pretty much
so then there was these two ladies I
wanted me and they they kind of were
fighting over who got to pick me for the
agency and then they left it up to me to
choose and I just chose the one on the
left and that's all I do an audition if
you wanted real bad and you didn't get
it near monk right by the way home babe
on it was the opposite I was crying no
like no hurts as an adult kid I
auditioned for this thing and they liked
me and they said aw you're so cute he's
so talented but I didn't speak Spanish
fluently enough for the role was on
Univision and and they were like we love
him above all in front of me and then
they called my agent or my mom later and
we're like we don't want yes and then my
mom told me that and I started bawling
in the car and then and then she just
like that's all that she is she goes
she's like are you done okay because
that's the last time you crying or else
I'm not taking you to any more auditions
Wow okay yeah it is it's true because
you're gonna get like a hundred knows if
you sit there and cry complain about it
like you know that's wasting time and it
also affects your future auditions if
you take them so hard you're gonna be
stressed and worried about the next one
instead of going being light-hearted you
know I think it was George Clooney who
said he started getting booked when he
stopped caring before he went into the
audition yeah like I stopped caring and
I stopped I didn't think of it I was
like I'm not gonna get it whatever I
don't care I'm just gonna go and do it
the only words for him well Corey Corey
Holcomb good
he doesn't remember any lies well there
was none even knowing the lies he
distracts this is embarrassing member
you want to show a BBC an applicant or
extra sex with Ricky Gervais and this
I've seen in a show where he they want
him to play like this um this character
in a play and when they they wanted but
when they get there he's there with his
manager right yeah when they get to the
casa directive or right in front of his
face I don't want this guy I want Tim
what Tim is not here Jim couldn't do it
because he broke in later i well Russell
a rusty couldn't do it
I want bill Lemke anybody goes there
that's my client
I'm right here I'll call him hey watch
it - I took my other claim you couldn't
get a hold on I was pulling on my pocket
that's a phone number yeah what a
manager role that's funny
somebody said you audition for the
fluffy movie to me yeah I actually I did
how does Mario know that I was here
probably a little kid in the video a
while ago I remember that I know the kid
that got it because I've seen him in a
couple auditions before for like the
Nickelodeon stuff and you know Big Ups
to him you know that's awesome you did
he killed everyone and then I know there
was this other thing that wasn't related
but it was like a stand-up skit of
Gabriel Iglesias that I did well they
actually put a wig on me because I had
really long hair at the time and I did
the one of his famous skits or his jokes
about the game thing or they oh yeah
it's Dance Revolution Jackie last
weekend
hey some guy a fan his video bro um
thanks but on Facebook but this guy is
Jackie Escalera he said go there
introduce me or tell him coming here
like this guy's the one I busted out the
Bill Cosby album on this picture price
at the first time ever her stand up with
in his garage kids yeah so he look give
me an album so this kid didn't know like
he doesn't know who you know comedy you
know just yet know either karma karma
they don't know no be yeah there are no
personal shadings and and whenever
people approach me and say you're the
Kelly's were fluffy yeah man what's up
man how's fluffy bro he's out there
making millions brother more ever get
hundreds yeah you know I made a joke
about you know I don't nobody know [ __ ]
so this well Jackie's killer a soft
fluffy he was saying well Starbucks you
were selling autograph at Starbucks
taking selfies with people Weight
Watchers probably Jackie Jackie said he
says what's up with Felipe and he said
he said his face turn and he goes man
bro any name but that name walked away
and then he walked away and he doesn't
know he's a fan are you walking away
from a spread that to the fan yeah don't
bring him into this [ __ ] straight
Compton Irwin when [ __ ] Ice Cube
issue in the Big Easy
yeah
what's the other one Erik Estrada I saw
a movie brother we're gonna talk about
next week
you probably looks a good triple movie
premiere tomorrow
Wendy Wendy what's up man your son come
over fix my bike a publishing
SuperSonics Wendy oh and manic Veronica
maybe ever if you have any advice or ya
bum $100 you talk to her for 30 minutes
about how to get into the business 5000
they can introduce you to Felipe the
publicist if you're shy get the [ __ ] out
of here with this if you if you hate
being the bad guy just job enough for
you yeah it's like if you if you like it
like someone look it gives you a look
like this [ __ ] [ __ ] why is she
bringing this guy to me you're not in
the right business this business cold
hearted bro then we got published in
fighting oh but other publicists yeah
now you show up right there you another
published I don't your client what's up
what you doing me I get to the same
movie you could [ __ ] better seats I got
this kind of [ __ ] lukewarm coke [ __ ]
here we get there bro and you're [ __ ]
up you go to a movie or a TV show yeah
and your [ __ ] trailer and the other
actors opposed to leave is doing there
that's never happened to me Oh bad what
actors what you know how you leave your
trailer mmm she liked me like without a
name mm-hmm but I still there - what
were they using it right away
no they wouldn't yeah read your trailer
I won't tell my left when I was doing
taco shop the movie I took home I was
like going through stuff bro right so I
thought the meaning of the top of the
millennium bro and nobody and it was
dumb they could call me [ __ ] man for
that one
but it was I took at least I was at the
zoo I think I didn't have that the star
trailer with two doors bro I had that
you know I had that little trailer where
I'm where the sometimes the toilet is
under the seat but I had a little tiny
toilet room so I took a dump and when I
when I flushed it in like a petal yeah
right but everything was dogs the Athena
washer yeah yeah they didn't have a
little sprayer that's the honey was
leaving man and then but then I like to
leave right away bro gonna take a dump
but I didn't leave right away I went to
go sign up and lollygag with some food
then when I was leaving
all right I saw the PA guy with a
plunger bro and the scrub and I'm so
fine that which was definitely and he
looked at me all sweaty
damn does his job and I'm looking at me
like I looked at him he looked at me and
he put his head down that's a mirror so
you seen my work before huh
you're gonna autograph your plunger puto
what's the biggest job you ever took
brother said I don't think you're gonna
get this question on any other thing
I've ever taken like that big on set but
like at home bring your mom on the line
she said you left something at home this
morning
no you go first what's your biggest you
like this owe me bro when I was like cuz
I'm bein also but I'm also over like was
[ __ ] I wasn't like going through
hemorrhoids so I was like holding back a
lot broke another one the other one you
know I raped but log you know if it
hurts it burns but I held it in for
three days bro you guys ever seen that
commercial
colon blow that's Saturday Night Live
Saturday live look at how Brooklyn it
was it almost meaning out of the toilet
bro I had to blur twice and then I
stabbed it bro
I took four hot water that makes it
smell give it a name but tell her
goodbye I got so scared because I hit a
corner top I took linen I got so scared
to my mom's mom I don't know what to do
it's not going down and she comes in
she's like and then she she goes up and
she's like you have to cut it I made a
lot of cookies oh I don't know what I
probably booze or something just kidding
actually she gave me the thing she's
like here you do I came back again and
then flushed it it was like you guys
need to take those shits to Denali Park
a photo of it yeah photo yes you do with
it since my friend oh yeah man see girls
can't do that taking a picture of a [ __ ]
and sent it to a friend I've never
farted around a girlfriend none nothing
like that only you because I can't
escape you at home you're there it's
funny but like we have like two
restrooms ah and like oh it was Reza you
gonna go to right and she was saying
like the closer one so I got a real
party hose with my restroom
yeah totally just runs out bro it sucks
man you shoot yourself before huh the
other Fae that's the want to shoot
himself in high school the face of
someone who did in high school I did in
high school I thought it was a fart
Johnny Appleseed first period second
period oh that my friend tough after
school I saved up
yeah yeah my son does not go to the
bathroom at school all day
that's gross and then he waits to go at
home yeah like he doesn't but he's like
he's afraid of who might be in there
bully us like that at our house Isaac's
in their bathroom taking a long time in
there and you're like what are you doing
in there
or I'm in the bathroom we have no door
on our bathroom in our master bathroom
and he comes walking by I like taking
shape blowing it up huh nuclear no but
sometimes we have to have them share a
room every once in a while like when
there's no budget or whatever for that
city hmm but it's not as much anymore
now that we can get a room for Johnny
but sometimes you would stay with him
right just fart in this stunk up I know
it's gross like it's a random one Torr
do you come in after he's done it and
something happened really one up and it
smells like yeah it smells like now you
know when you take a [ __ ] right and like
you just say like you get it you're numb
and you put the toilet paper you hid it
somewhere but no smiling they won't go
away I mean the rumors cold those days
it I know we started with a new story
about [ __ ] but like all right here we go
do you think she's and poops killing me
tell me it's Sam okay we had a
discussion did we resolve this
discussion oh I haven't seen the movie
but I harbor two different rather than
two different times okay what shows
salmon Captain Marvel two different
writers yeah at the different times all
50 states
Captain Marvel or DC yeah Captain Marvel
whoever came up with that man
that comic book when we read right they
use a little closer Superman right but
the only thing that was the same was
that Captain Marvel used the word Shazam
yeah but Shazam is a whole different
character
he wasn't Captain Marvel she was that
one little boy that turns into shows
that night that Marvel with always
Captain Marvel does it a boy right hmm
but when they were sued they were
calling him Captain Marvel yeah
in Shazam for a while yeah but then they
were like no way we have a character
named Captain Marvel no I mean Superman
said my comics where were made Superman
said that II seen characters too close
to [ __ ] Superman Captain Marvel yeah
she had a stay in [ __ ] power you fly
does everything the same we gonna change
it so then F will became Shazam later on
right the Captain Marvel still exists
well okay no more you're a conscious
exams the name of a wizard that gives
him that you have a kid the power right
and like eventually he's a Greek god is
there involving this one well the Greek
gods are the power that he receives
calling out Shazam name right so but he
eventually takes on the name of Shazam
but is he ever Captain Marvel well in
the earlier one thing but II I only know
the TV show from the 70s
yeah used to be Captain Marvel before
and I think it was it was Oh before they
were even DC Comics I think they were
like yeah but it was I think ace here I
think it was Action Comics thing is one
around that yeah and and that's when
they were Superman's first yeah yeah and
that's when they did they had him as
Captain Marvel and then they got into a
lawsuit I think so then they they had to
kind of like take back to the name and
at one point they had his logo just be
like a square or like a circle because
they couldn't put like the Captain
Marvel thing I guess on the title and
they don't want to get into any legal
issues so then later on I know that
Shazam became his own thing separate
after after that whole like lawsuit
thing and there was I think one where it
was just about the adult version and
then there was like two other one
like Shazam tallish isn't big or
something like that which and then there
was the another Marvel family but it was
like slimmed down it was Captain Marvel
jr. Mary Marvel whiz comics yeah yeah
that was my favorite but see Marvel's
Captain Marvel was entirely different
yeah it's very new and you know an alien
hero came to conquer before yeah so it's
not the same guy as Shazam though and
that's what you kept saying at first and
I was confused yeah Marvel Captain
Marvel from Marvel thing
well that's all similar to Superman they
had to I liked scrapped the name too
because those two movies came out of on
the same time yeah and with with Shazam
I've it's this one's based off of the
new 52 comics are enough you guys yeah
yeah and then a lot of their newer stuff
that they're writing right now I'm
assuming is where they're trying to add
with the story so no man I'm excited for
part two for that movie fresh Azam yeah
yeah look able to you know I just yeah I
know partly shorter party short man
gorgeous I mean funny when people like
throw your name on you - he put you in
the movie he's good dude hey bro you
ever get to like you're working in a
movie and they're like these chicks with
one lines trying to make sure they get
that one line in scene stealers I don't
get an extra line you're late I want to
be in a scene with him and Eugene they
like you but you would have been a scene
with you just get their face what I know
that what other superstars I would have
been a scene with him and like you're in
the show all week yeah so we busy but
before a lot of the fans like they want
to be funny huh mm-hmm
of the very back row they've been
demanding may I hope so do ya fans have
been asking for you to return but they
they keep old episode brother deported
ever come back
that story for cornelio went forever yes
me Cody
yeah that's for Corinne you see I made
up my own I dried myself in Jobar so
that's very good
I'm also gonna be in there the venom
part to play carnage asada so what's
next bed for Jovan bro what's ours so
moving this [ __ ] yeah blow up like chris
farley I'm buddy the bean in your movie
the brawl playing a grandfather one day
Sam to you'll be the you'll be the
Mexican Santa I'll be somebody you
member Santa Claus Santa Claus yeah yeah
yeah he freaks out throughout the entire
movie yeah mi swear fluffy right now I
like taking a change your voice it
together Barack now to tell you what
it's like to be a man you have to do
these things and to be Barack Obama you
have to kind of do this thing and it's
wine and want me to be clear
so ya wrong want you to watch the photo
Gabriel a surfer special oh my god copy
it take off yes Perez bro whatever they
do be here to enact John you wanna hang
out let's do it do you um do you do have
to keep your acting chops fresh due to
the acting classes not anymore
no it's a bad [ __ ] huh yeah I
just I just go up based off of my own
thing but if there is a role where I
feel like it's a little intense I will
take coaching I'm not I'm not like you
know stubborn man like I know
everything's everything there's always
room for learning and I feel like the
day you stop learning is when you should
stop acting yeah
I think I think that every week bro you
still care about no lies you don't try
all the time that much or you go you
don't hard-code sit and memorize I don't
think you have it in you no he just
doesn't sit and was I staring my actions
mm-hmm know what I really gotta say but
I'm saying or whatever trying to
comprehend to the Maya who ever I'm
talking to yeah I know what to say it
cuz yeah like once you know the the
process is who was here for you cuz I
when I was shooting on Monday I got that
I would not know about knocking the
lines down but then I took my time and I
gave my lord do it a little hug honey I
came hug you know me know I'm [ __ ]
with him to a fighting guy like in a
comfort zone where he is my friend real
life and we're gonna move in the theme
and I just you know I'm gonna [ __ ]
Freddie real life Pro profit but I was
just [ __ ] with your hugging no bro then
I got out warm that I realized that our
here's my friend yeah we started walking
down I actually had a more physical
stuff and um but the last take the last
take we did was you know they film you
closer
besides and then it shot one from far
away when I should have shut home far
away is a wide shot brought know my
lines bro like I've been like a
[ __ ] know and they could use
that dialogue to put it in when I [ __ ]
up but yeah but I don't know little it
look good in my way now and Netflix
award there isn't like the comfort that
really makes it easier to learn lines
yeah but see mine was tough for me is
that I'm I'm a stand-up comedian bro so
I I am I [ __ ] I crave bro you can
accept this bro I crave immediate um how
you say immediate arm inspection
immediate interaction immediate laugh
immediate attention
yeah you know like most comics so I
never do my lines and they say cut I
look around to see who laughs that
feedback their response yeah I demand
fast feedback profile so if I do a joke
aligned with pause it
to my next line mm-hmm the one an
applause break but a lot of comics do
that when they start to become actors
Jerry Seinfeld was doing it like just a
lot of people do it because you're
waiting for this time I was good bro I
took my time bro because I thought I
didn't rush it
no man yeah I'm good I'm getting good
her how about you bro well how do you
how do you prepare yourself for that
road man
well obviously for Shazam I had to do my
research I looked up some comic books I
I read new 52 flashpoint kingdom come
and just a couple other ones just kind
of you know brush up on the other
universes you know that the tone and the
character that I got Pedro Pena he's so
new there's no like real description
it's just like shy Latino asthmatic and
that was it you know there's nothing
crazy to go off of so I just kind of
made up my own thing my own backstory
where like maybe there's something where
that happened with his family so he ran
away or something like that or maybe his
parents are both dead because you're got
that Bruce Wayne life you know but he's
quiet there's gotta be a reason why he's
quiet you know he's to himself right is
it like his time every 15 minutes
well two whistles so yeah i just i just
do my research and then going on set
you know David Sandberg he's amazing to
work with he's definitely helped guide
whenever but it's funny because you were
talking about how like that you need
that immediate like response where you
feel like you did good that's that's how
I felt on this set cuz like I did I
would do some things and then like what
do you think about that David and he's
like it's good and I'm like yeah tell me
it's great sound like you mean it movie
bro well they were giving away hilarious
to everybody yeah like I got two ways to
have pretty bit of hilarious
he had the whole crew laughing don't no
way whole do you man how long were tell
they said that today
everybody they did like even like the
bridesmaids order that was hilarious and
I was like no it was it
what's up for show days this weekend
I'll be an Albuquerque New Mexico Ysleta
resort that's a long time nice leather
resort April 27 this Saturday it's gonna
be real real Torres Martin Rizal Larry
Bowa Brown yeah no no no no chill he's
back with the white hair Lincoln
California Sacramento area May 4th at
Thunder Valley Casino
Larry bubble Brown yes well the river
tourists
Los Angeles our Spanish Oh our Spanish
show at The Comedy Store May 16 our
Spanish total espanol we have Jack a
Latino there and we have our - rizal
killer in Spanish Martin Rizzo has been
on fire and Spanish lately he's a wiggle
I think he's got a stronger career in
Spanish than he does in English they
loved him and everybody California
Irvine improv May 22 to 26 Salinas
California Fox Theater baby May 31st
Stockton California the Bob Hope
theatres June 1st ready for Selena those
tickets are on sale this Thursday
tomorrow
in this won't air again until Friday but
it's live right now wait-wait-wait
tomorrow they go on sale for the for
fans with the code word ombre a bad I'm
but it's were H a.m. BR e and you can
get tickets presale from 10:00 a.m. to
10:00 p.m. tomorrow but on Friday the
public on sale starts and you don't need
a password for that let's go the bad
hombre - bro I know you did use them and
know that remember yeah give it any cool
gifts from Shazam yeah
[Laughter]
they gave us as a wrap gift to give us a
backpack and it was pretty cool I mean
they give us this water bottle thing and
I have some comic books that I could
actually give you we don't I don't know
my mom I have a whole box because I
actually went to an elementary school
and I asked him for a box so I could
give out to kids I don't want any comic
books through the house he's gonna lay
all over the floor everything it's gonna
it's it's Freddie's Journal after you
watch the movie okay I understand but
all the families are in it so it's got a
little family tree it's kind of cool
Johnny what you got going on Grover say
the shower oh my god supporting culture
Friday it's just some last night yeah
yeah yeah what they go don't skip town
Roger Lopez got love the guy threw me up
a little bit him if Terry where I me had
a baby it'll be Raja Lopez but we don't
have any people I think what some Roger
Lopez comedy funny funny ass dude we
should Daniel Webb Daniel Webb you know
where David went Daniel Daniel Webb I
think he's funny it was funny
who the favorite comedian growing up you
watch key locals no no no I think I
never really get into a local New York
of the people here did that come aboard
mm mm oh goes after right mm you started
coming in like 95 yeah no he was born in
93 so you were already oh
when was um when were you on
calicos 90 it's 98 to 2000 yeah yeah I
know I I watch comedy specials now but a
lot of the ones I watch just random ones
yeah I'll watch it Chris Rock one and
then I'll go some random person that I
don't know but I guess they're kind of
big because they have a Netflix special
but um how do you feel about comedy cuz
you're that age like my son what do you
think of like do you think that people
who are like Instagram comedians you
know who do funny skits and stuff do you
think those people are comedians just
the same as like a stand-up comic like
Felipe or Gabriel or Chris Rock or do
you see them the same very different no
they're very different some kids think
that's a comedian you know when they tag
somebody like that you know no those are
just like kind of like the like the
Viner type of people it's like they are
creative people and they have good
content that they they'll come up with
in their mind and then they'll record it
and it's like rehearsed or they have a
couple takes with santim comedy it's
like something you know you practice and
you just go up there and you know you're
in front of a crowd and whether they
like it or not you can't control you
gotta just go with it well a lot of
those bynars or youtubers or whatever
Instagram stars like what they'll do
though often not all the time but often
some of those people will take a joke
that already exists from a comic and
turn it into a sketch and people don't
even know because there's wrong to know
the comedy source of that joke know that
somebody did you're not the life raft
joke but they didn't do it they did an
actual life raft opening up and then
have the medium up there of what was
going you know when you take a woman
home from the club whatever it was his
joke but just visuals on YouTube know is
Instagram shut out to have your Papa
have your pompe oh he said what I'm
trying to say because the Dow the line
from Mad Dog glory the reason I'm a
stand-up comedian because I am I crave
instant gratification over actual
achievements mm-hmm I need to watch that
movie
says right yeah yeah yeah Papa no
related to G papa a little bit so what's
up food you bring a ton of end game with
other in I don't know I haven't watched
it but I see posters everywhere now
everybody's excited so uh well my next
project I know I'm attached to a couple
scripts I don't know what's happening
with them as of right now but one is
being pitched to NBC it's a
predominantly african-american Latino
cast so maybe we'll throw you in there
man it's actually shooting as a pilot or
they're just it's a pilot yeah friendly
thing about that role but it's it's
being pitched to NBC and Oprah Winfrey
so we'll see which one picks it up and
then as far as like just next projects
I'm auditioning I got a couple meetings
general meetings with Nickelodeon
animation dream arcs so I'll see what's
coming what you told you tell your kids
I want to be an actor bro that has a mom
that not motivated get emancipated I
don't know
where's your parents yeah well if you go
back to book if it's something that
you're really passionate about I would
say find an agent and you know get
guidance and find a manager once you
start booking so that you know you're
not alone in this business cuz that's
something that you definitely need you
need a team and that's something I'm I'm
thankful that I have I have my agents my
PR my managers so if I ever need if I
don't know what's going on I like go to
my lawyer I'd be like this is some right
to you he's like no we gotta do this
isn't that so definitely get a team with
a Carosa
Lisa you're looking fine as hell you so
what's up boo thank you very much but
where can people find your music what's
your Twitter first of all my Twitter and
Facebook and everything else is Javon
arm on that straight OVA na are ma and D
Instagram its Siobhan amount official
all right man was so with that chain bro
they wrote that
I don't know you have the throw beeper
anyone got the beeper look badass Jade
what the were changed or friggin
snatched nothing this is from a
sponsorship just from that ass What's Up
boo look at the little regular piggy
gonna kiss the Indian that's what
everybody norm Boyle has East LA bro
when I walk in kid the pinky legit he
said sparse right here we got Johnny no
finer man a man if anybody wasn't acting
classes from a decent person called
Debra Lyman lemon men2 her for four
years I think I got more acting class
that I do Rose and if you guys want to
get your kids on a hit show on Disney
pay $5,000 you can be Philly back